I came to this meeting us thinking that
I was a beleaguered minority
representing mad dog physicalism and I'm
very relieved to discover that so far
from being a mad dog so far from being a
beleaguered minority well my differences
with others especially people of whose
views I have long respected our matters
of emphasis and shading um that's very
reassuring to me um it's also extremely
important and valuable but for a group
like this to get together in the
complete absence of non-naturalistic we
can let our hair down and express what
we really believe without worrying about
its ramifications for broader debates um
that's why I regret that this is
videotaped and being put on YouTube um
there's only one issue that I regret we
did not discuss at greater length so
that I could get a clearer handle on it
um we had a persistent disagreement
around the table about emergence and
some of us insists that there is there
is emergence and it is not a problem for
naturalism and of course adjudicating
this claim requires us to pin down a
concept of emergence and I don't think
it's going to require us to pin down a
concept of naturalism because I think
there we are all pretty much in the same
region of conceptual space and of course
it's too late to do that now but that is
the one regret that
our agenda
you